et pour tout ce qui concerne le
transport vous pouvez me faire confiance
et à aucun risque il ya toujours des
risques avec moi ils sont minimisés dans
les combien tu peux transporter par
camion
je dirais 500 kg sans attirer
l'attention 500 kg vous avez de la
chance d'en être sorti vivant c'est du
lourd celui là c'est lui qui contrôle
adams district maintenant son casier
quand il était gamin il a gagné ses
galons comme dealer il a fait cinq ans
pour coups et blessures et trois de plus
pour trafic de drogue une bande rivale
lui a piqué son stock l'an dernier au
lieu d'envoyer toute sa bande faire des
représailles
il les a pourchassés en un pour le
dépecer au couteau personnellement très
bien voici ce que je propose je parle
devant témoins nous arrêtons monsieur
anderson et j'ai réduit la peine de dec